yo big spoilers this show is fantastic
and i definitely recommend you see it
before watching this video
i swear robert kirkman's entire career
plan was to create beloved comic
characters and then have steven yun
portray them being brutalized by someone
with a mustache and you know what
he made it work good for him invincible
is a new animated series that is to put
it lightly
everything i've been hoping for out of a
comic book adaptation my
entire life it's exactly what i've
wanted in comic book story is being
brought to new mediums and i think it's
fair to say this is a
perfect adaptation of the beloved comic
while i'll personally never forgive him
for traumatizing me at age 7 with marvel
zombies
robert kirkman is undoubtedly one of the
most experimental and brave storytellers
in comics
because he's not afraid to do something
different and unique
and shockingly violent nothing
exemplifies that more than his and
co-creator corey walker's 2003 superhero
comic
invincible basically invincible is a
superhero world where the rules of
marvel and dc
don't apply if a character is killed off
they stay dead
if a villain wins that just stays
if something dark and depressing happens
the book unashamedly takes the time to
really weigh the consequences and fall
out of that in a mature and realistic
way
but in spite of this the book isn't so
much of a critique of superheroes as it
is a loving celebration of them
the book has its extreme low points for
its characters but it allows them to
have high points and successes too
in spite of it all it's never cynical i
find that more realistic than a book
where everything is bad
and depressing and everyone is miserable
the entire time with no reprieves of
happiness
and everyone is an unlikable [ __ ]
life has
downs and ups it'd really do be like
that
it stars mark grayson aka invincible as
the young superhero son of the world's
most powerful hero omni-man
the series follows mark's day-to-day
adventures dealing with a social life
the inner politics of the superhero
community and the crushing weight of a
potential life-ending
alien invasion from a race that's even
stronger than he is
who were actually the source of his and
his father's powers
some of the bigger themes are
immortality and what life would be like
for someone who can live to be five
thousand years old
or how easy it might be to become
disconnected from one's humanity if
someone became
too smart or too strong with superheroes
routinely losing their ability to have
normal lives
as their powers grow and while the comic
came to its conclusion in 2018
it's found a second life as an animated
series on amazon prime
amazon prime like the 8th best way to
watch tv
what can i say except this show
represents everything there is to love
about the comic but fixes some of its
most glaring flaws
the storylines and invincible are
compelling heartfelt and grossing and
unpredictable it's truly one of those
comics that once it gets going it's hard
to put down
but i found myself struggling with its
slow and scattered pacing a few times
when i read it
often there'd be a character or
storyline introduced at one point
and then not followed up on for scores
of issues
this proves that kirkman was really
thinking ahead and had the entire thing
planned out from the beginning
which is a great thing but sometimes the
foreshadowing became a little
frustrating when i knew it wouldn't
amount to anything for
50 more issues because so many other
events were put ahead of it
this leads to a feeling of stopping and
starting with some stories where you're
fascinated to know more about this
villain or their plan
or this backstory or this character's
little side thing and
and then the book seemingly forgets that
exists for ages
this show manages to dodge this by
taking full advantage of its longer
running time
with nearly hour-long episodes there's a
lot more time for amazon's invincible to
reorganize and reinterpret the flow of
these events
but ultimately not changing a thing
about them for example
in the comic we find out that this
student at mark's college d.a sinclair
is kidnapping people off the street and
turning them into nearly indestructible
cyborg minions that he wants to sell to
the military
he even kidnaps a friend of marx named
rick mark's best friend william asks him
to go looking for rick
and at the time mark has already wrapped
up in an unrelated storyline is just
like
yeah i'll get around to it and it takes
him months to find the time for it
this storyline could have been resolved
in like three issues maximum
but is sprinkled throughout the first 38
issues of the book
the show's response was to consolidate
all of these events into
a single episode so we get the entire
beginning
middle and end in one sitting without
any of the distractions
i find the show version preferable
because it doesn't reflect as badly on
our main character
he goes looking for his friend that very
same day instead of putting a ton of
other things first
good work show mark [ __ ] that other guy
and this show does things like that all
the time like using the plot about one
of mark's superhero friends
robot becoming more human with a cloned
body
something that took 20 plus issues to
handle in the book was split across
three or four episodes as a side plot
and they changed the dialogue to hint at
a future event from much later in the
book
change the world
giving it more of a connective tissue
with what comes next for robot as a
character
i've seen some people complain that the
big twist about mark's father being evil
came
too early in the show having only been
at the end of the first episode while it
took
six issues for the comic i don't really
have a problem with this because this
show needed to get its hook in early
and having more than one episode of the
safe fun
lighthearted superhero stuff before the
violence came in
meant the audience would spend like two
or three weeks waiting for the shoe to
drop
and might give up on the show because of
its far more average mask at the
beginning
one episode was plenty of time and you
know what this show gives
us fans of the comic an entirely new way
to recommend this story to people
and then watch their horrified reaction
when things take a traumatic
brain explodey turn whatever i think
about comic adaptations i always see the
discussion about comic book accuracy and
whether or not that's a good thing or if
it's not important or
or what every side of the discussion
makes good points
like the whole fun of making shows and
movies like this
is to take something we've only seen in
drawings and still images
and then put them in motion with a layer
of realism that elevates the story to an
entirely
new level of believability it's one
thing to see a man fly in a drawing
but don or superman once made the world
believe a man could fly
in the real world so why wouldn't we
want to see all of our favorite moments
and characters in live action or
animation as accurately as possible on
the other hand
comics are just as valid of a
storytelling medium as movies and tv
a story is not made better or more valid
by simply being made into a big
budget hollywood movie sure that's the
art medium that the most people will
probably
see given you know the gap between
comics and marvel movies but the story
was
just fine as it was if you wanted it to
be as
pinpoint accurate as possible why not
just read the comic itself again
they may as well change at least
something so it's not totally redundant
and some translations need to be made
from one medium to another
comics are long-form serialized
storytelling with
massive casts of characters and
thousands of storylines all tangled
together at once
in an eight episode season or a two-hour
movie
you can't really use all of it so some
things need to be altered or simplified
to fit a new medium
invincible fits perfectly in the middle
of both sides of this debate
it shows us every important scene from
the comic and adapts them nearly shot
for
shot and word for word in some cases
don't you think she deserves to know the
truth
yeah but your mother knew he killed the
guardians but she was holding out hope
there was a good reason for it
so was i better for her to know
everything about your father
maybe you're right wait a minute where
are we
no sorry lights
that's enough lights
[Music]
you're fighting so you can watch
everyone around you die
think mark you'll outlast every fragile
insignificant being on this planet
everyone and everything you know
will be gone what will you have after
500 years
that
but also knows how to alter that to fit
a new medium
by enhancing what works and ignoring
what doesn't
the improvements to pacing the extra
time we get to spend with our characters
and get to know them better
and all the added context to flesh out
the already great world building
some things that the comic glosses over
or spends little time developing
get more of a closer look in the series
like the relationship between rex and
eve
rex cheating on eve their messy breakup
and his final attempt to win her back
is all off panel in the comic it's only
explained through quick exposition
and conversation because you have to
keep things moving when you're limited
to 22 pages of story
the amazon version shows instead of
tells
and it makes everything so much easier
to understand for the characters and
their mindsets
it strengthens the writing and our
connection to the story
and the series is smart enough to know
what to cut for relevance
there's a very early story in the comic
about a teacher at mark's high school
kidnapping students
and then turning them into cyborg human
bombs the show skips over this because
it already sounded a little too much
like the stuff with d.a sinclair and the
rihanna men
and between the two of them the rihanna
men are far more important as they have
a long
reaching implication and use for the
entire rest of the series
while this teacher subplot doesn't
really go anywhere
so they cut it and i totally get that
going forward i hope the show can cut
down on some of the unnecessary time
skips from the book
several times in the series something
will happen to mark where he's sent to
the past
or an alternate universe or just stuck
on an alien world
and during that time away a major time
skip will happen
it'll feel like only a few days or hours
for him and we'll be following that
pretty closely
but back on earth time is passing
rapidly he'll go back and things will be
incredibly different
it's like interstellar but like seven
different times this is a good way to
extend the scope of the story without
having to dwell too long on certain
parts
but happens so often and at times can be
very alienating
you're invested in the way things are
now when suddenly you blink and it's
nine months later and everything is
completely uprooted
it's not the feeling of change that's
bothersome but just how ungradual and
underdeveloped it is
sometimes we don't get to see huge
alterations in the world and characters
that would take a long time to develop
a magic wand is waved and they're just
different now
sometimes these time skips don't seem to
add anything except
punching down at mark unfairly to make
it more miserable than necessary
and it happens so often it becomes
redundant i think the show could once
again
take advantage of the gaps between
seasons and use those as spaces in the
story instead of these
numerous on-screen time leaps instead of
mark being trapped in a paper bag for
five months and then coming out to find
out his grandma has moved into their
house with her two siberian tigers
off-screen or whatever
just have that happen between seasons
and then catch us up without mark
getting stuck like a doofus four or five
times
yes an occasional fish out of water main
character is fine
and that'll give exposition for us as
the audience but we don't need our main
character
constantly running around asking
everyone what happened while he was on a
business trip to hang out with
spider-man
he can be present for some of these
things man but hey that might not be
something really to consider until like
season 4 or whatever
i'm thinking too far ahead i am so happy
this show exists so it can serve as the
ultimate example of what i've always
wanted from comic adaptations
just follow the story exactly as it is
in a long-term format
and make it better by strengthening the
pillars of that story and ignoring its
weaker points
and i love that it's an animated
superhero show for adults
we haven't had anything like this since
spawn i like to think that cartoon is
somehow canon to this one
it just takes place 20 years ago before
mark was even born
cause like there's some overlap having
hour-long episodes gives it this weight
and maturity because you know they want
to really dive deep and develop concepts
instead of just doing something quick
and light like a villain of the week
show
the only other superhero cartoon i can
think of with an episode
time like this was justice league but
for the sake of fitting on network
television all those were split up into
two parters and aired a week apart
thank god we live in the future being
animated is definitely a plus because
there's no
doubt about whether an effects heavy
costume or character design
major storyline or action set piece
would be cut because it would be
unfilmable on a television budget
these fight scenes simply couldn't exist
in live action
without being expensive as all hell and
at that point it probably wouldn't even
be a tv show
i know there's a live action adaptation
of invincible in the works
a movie but i'm happy with just this
i don't need a single thing else i know
the movie will have to
cut out side characters heavily condense
the plot
leave out major swaths of world building
because it's handcuffed to a two-hour
running time
nah man let all this breathe let us live
in this world and with these characters
for longer
the small human moments we get are what
make them special
not just the spectacle of the action
everything with mark just being a normal
and relatable guy
and all of his internal struggles with
the morality and existential dread of
his life
are exactly the first things they'd cut
to make a movie on this scale work
but that's the stuff that makes the
story good what really makes amazon's
invincible special
is that it preserves that image comic
seal
under the image banner comics are all
owned by their creators
the story goes how they want it to go
they do with it as they please
the comic ends when they want it to and
they don't have to share their
characters with anyone they don't want
to
that still applies even with the show
because both of invincible's co-creators
are directly involved with making it
robert kirkman wrote the pilot and the
finale for the first season
and corey walker is doing all of the
show's character designs
there is no doubt about it here the
characters talk how they talk
and look how they'd look it's perfectly
authentic
kirkman's characters are still his own
to control
and maybe they don't resemble walker's
earliest art but if you look at his more
recent stuff
it's definitely just the show's art
style and sequential art form
the fact that both of these co-creators
are directly working on the show
really legitimizes it as still being a
creator-owned story
just with a much bigger team and a new
set of tools to work with
i think that's incredibly valuable and
more comic writers and artists would
probably
love to have that level of say in how
their work is being presented
in another format this should be the
standard especially after hearing
stories of
other comic creators being screwed out
of royalties for their ideas being used
in movies and shows on the marvel and dc
front
sometimes they aren't even credited
properly invincible sets a whole new
precedence for comic book to tv
adaptations
in so many ways and going forward it can
be the standard of what i look for in
these sorts of projects
what do i want them to do with
spider-man just this just tell the story
but smoother pacing and a few extraneous
or silly ideas left out
a great voice cast and don't be afraid
to let things get a little mature
having a long-running animated show
allows for the best development and you
never have to worry if an idea is
skirting the line of being unfilmable
if you haven't seen invincible already
it's absolutely worth your time
it's a show that excels by playing with
your expectations
making you think about heavy
philosophical questions
by letting us really get to know some
amazingly written characters
and then exploding some of their heads
and disemboweling them
i know it's going to feel like an
eternity but all welcome it back with
open arms when it's time for season two
this show has the potential to be
[Music]
[Music]
you